hello we begin with some breaking news
and the libyan warlord khalifa haftar
has announced his bid for next month's
presidential race he stepped down from
his military role in september paving
the way to run for the presidency haftad
headed the eastern-based libyan national
army and waged war against the
internationally recognized government
our libya correspondent malek traynor is
joining us here in doha so um
there were reports that this could
possibly happen and now it has so is
this a surprise it's not a surprise i
mean when we saw have to resign from his
position in september the expectation
that was that he was preparing himself
uh to announce his candidacy so no
surprise here at the moment and malik
important to note that uh
he is wanted for for war crimes is he
not well he's definitely he's he's he's
not wanted for war crimes but he's
definitely accused of working
against humanity yeah so but but in
libya he is in the tripoli courts he is
accused of war crimes and they have a
warrant out on his arrest
uh but there's he controls eastern libya
and the western government can't really
apply their power uh the internationally
recognized government applied their
power in eastern libya so he's been you
know free to to continue on in his
position in eastern libya so what you're
saying is his support base then is in
eastern libya what about across the
country how much support would he have
for for his candidacy
well during hafter launched the military
campaign on tripoli in 2019 in april
2019 and for 14 months his forces
pounded the capital uh hundreds of
thousands of people were displaced
hundreds of thousands of homes uh were
destroyed and so in western libya it's
he has he doesn't have much support but
in eastern libya he does have a support
pace there where are we in the process
of
the upcoming elections in december we
now have uh hafta who's announced his
candidacy uh just a few days ago we also
heard that islam gaddafi the son of
mohammed gaddafi announced his candidacy
so
what happens next in this process
well so there's supposed to be a
constitutional framework that so right
at the moment there's two legislative
sides in libya rival sides one in
eastern libya and one in western libya
according to a previous agreement
they're supposed to come up with a
constitutional framework to hold
elections that hasn't happened yet and
what that means is who can run for
elections what kind of power does the
president even have so those are those
remain to be uh they're still not agreed
upon and you know in western libya
yesterday we saw uh people protesting
in front of the election election office
saying that you know having presidential
elections without a constitution is
paving the way to bring back a
total totalitarian rule to libya
threatening the future democracy so
how likely is it that these elections
actually take place as scheduled
to be honest nobody knows i mean we can
say that we we think that they are going
to go on there's a lot of international
pressure on the various libyan parties
for for them to hold the elections as
scheduled uh but now as we saw was safe
for islam and now with hafter we're
going to see a lot of tension happen a
lot of political divisions and we're
going to see people on the ground say
that these elections without a
constitutional framework uh without the
powers uh decided on what a president
has that these were will further
instability and conflict in libya okay
thank you malik trina is our libya
correspondent